are you excited Evan let's try let's see
this is scary though look that's what we
get in okay I think about a skeleton oh
my God so means you after you're done
you die I hope not whole thing Nina
there you go
Tammy you are an animal that's amazing
we're going to uh the gallery Lafayette
which is a famous shopping area malls uh
stores and we'll see how much Nina Buys
so I could buy anything I want
yes we don't have to rush we're staying
in Paris so
surprises are coming stay tuned
[Music]
I had a good night's sleep but I checked
my aura ring said have seven hours of
what seven hours only 71 score I'm
filming you you're feeling me yeah at 71
score I'm telling the story because I
want to okay
cheers to everybody
have a rough night
stayed up too late
too late I'm 69 sleep yeah it was just I
was oh I'm not any better I'm only 71
score we went to bed at 140. and then
and then it would already tell me that
to take it easy today and then I woke up
at five for an hour or something for
some reason it's okay
today we still got a fun day but we
don't have to rush we're staying in
Paris so
surprised does it come stay tuned
had a good breakfast you had a good
breakfast oh I was so full I couldn't
eat that much I didn't even feel I
didn't even go for a second place
okay we're gonna walk the city ever say
it's a three kilometer away I said why
don't we just walk and see how we feel
four kilometers away about an hour
okay so it's about four kilometers away
and now we're a walk so why don't we
just do the walking get some exercise in
to burn off the breakfast calorie
and then we'll see how we're feeling
amazing view of Paris amazing okay let's
go
[Music]
Okay evan huh I see the palace yeah
we're going to the Palace uh it's a it's
a basilica it's not a palace okay it's
like a church okay but it looks like a
palace
well why not okay if Nina was in charge
that would be a palace and Nina is in
charge okay what's so good about that
what's so good about that oh I don't
know this is the palace
Church well that's a palace
I don't know I don't know the history
apart from it's beautiful it's big and
uh because it's on a hill we get to see
great views of Paris
all right we're almost here just have to
climb up this hill okay fast alarm no no
fast alarm fast information we have a
detail and then we'll be there in five
minutes three minutes three minutes okay
let's go
[Music]
all right we finally got to the top it's
busy it's very busy but the view is nice
so you'll be later at night but it's
okay because we're here in love
foreign
[Music]
where are we going next I am finding our
directions okay hurry up okay we're
going to uh the gallery Lafayette which
is the famous shopping area malls uh
stores and we'll see how much Nina buys
so I could buy anything I want yes
thank you
[Music]
so we got really a tire while I got
tired so I need to sit down and just
chill a little bit and then we came to
this coffee shop and uh in the mall
we're gonna have some drink relax a
little bit and then head to our way
we got two Ginger shots every time when
I see shots I need to do Ginger shots
not not alcohol shop but Ginger shot I
haven't got a matcha latte cold oh no
it's hot hot
and of course we are in France I have to
have a glass of wine a rose cheers
drink it down shot shot
it's good huh
definitely not good okay it's good for
your health it goes down smooth but then
there's a kick at the end whole thing
Nina
there you go
yummy and then that's it no cake no
there's a kick on the throat you're you
are an animal
it's amazing
[Music]
all right okay what happened Nina so I
didn't get any bag but I saw Pandora
I like to collect different city or
country Pandora and I got Paris just got
on her wrist I have different cities so
what's this one you're going to show us
this one is I have to open it this one
has the um the Eiffel Tower
Chandelier and then there's another one
that I I don't really quite know but I
can show you okay maybe I know maybe
foreign
next up we're gonna go to the 3D virtual
reality experience we're gonna fly you
over Paris and France in VR apparently
but let's see
foreign
[Music]
this is it
this is it are you excited Evan let's
try let's see this is scary though look
what
that's what we get in okay but they put
a skeleton oh my God so it makes you
after you're done you die I hope not
safe driver
okay so uh the appointment's at 4 50.
yeah so we're gonna walk to 10 minute
walk through the wax museum yeah and
then we're gonna come back here wax
museum maybe we'll take a picture with
some celebrity celebrity is there Nina
Carmichael in the wax museum
right here
you look too real
[Music]
so there's a huge line to go to the wax
museum
we're gonna check
if they're just getting tickets or
they're waiting to get in
if too busy then we're gonna head our
way back to somewhere else so it will be
over 40 minutes to wait in line to get
into the walk to museum even with
tickets yeah with tickets so and then so
we're feeling that we need we need to
eat some greens because we haven't
really have any greens for the last four
days
is it yeah wait wait wait wait where's
my hand going wait your finger looks so
tiny there there we're gonna eat
something look at how long your arm
looks eat salad yeah
[Music]
so another change up to the plants you
want to tell why we changed up the plant
Evan
look at how weird my head looks so small
compared to yours okay why don't you
just hold the camera then because it
works uh what are we doing so
Paris VR experience got some negative
reviews around seasickness old
technology and glasses that weren't
clean
I mean I barely wanted to go anyway so
we're gonna skip that
just enjoyed our our salad and instead
of doing that we're gonna go back to our
hotel and uh
okay
with to an in-room couples massage
right yeah
let's go
we had a relaxing massage yes did you
feel good yes I almost fell asleep when
she massaged my legs but at one point
was kind of hurt but it but it overall
is good good yeah oh yeah almost fell
asleep yeah we're gonna head out for a
lunch no dinner it's lunch time in
Canada yeah it's lunchtime kind of a
dinner dinner I'm hungry what's your
dinner I don't know we're gonna go see
maybe something healthy yeah okay
anyways let's go
[Music]
do you have a message for believe Nation
marry somebody you love
makes a big difference okay I didn't
expect that
did not expect that okay that's a good
message good message yeah
[Music]
I forget what's inside it but here we go
oh wow it's good tried the shrimp too
I don't know
oh good oh no all right yeah good job
[Music]
try your pasta well the chicken cordon
bleu with which
chicken is breaded with sauce
yum yum
[Music]
huh
yeah
Nina's going in on the lamb yeah and
then here it is Grace Lamb with couscous
very hot just like eels
very moist see I knew what you're gonna
say tasty the sauce is great too yeah
see I know all right there it is
going back to the hotel we're gonna have
Nina wants her wine yeah and tomorrow
we're going to Versailles the big Palace
of Versailles they trip going to be
there take lots of videos have lots of
exciting surprises so if you want to see
what we do there go cook the weird video
right there we'll see you there believe